I love that you click on my face and I
love that we have these weekly Westeros
visits I'm gonna miss them when they're
gone before we get started I do want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by Dr Squatch
which is changing the way men approach
hygiene by making our shower routines
feel better be better and for nothing
else helping us to smell better their
products made in the USA I appreciate
the fact that they use natural
ingredients rather than those harsh
chemicals found in some other brands not
only do they offer soap shampoo
conditioner deodorant beard oil and
because tis the season they're rolling
out their Halloween themes stick of the
Dead brick of the Dead werewolf wash
feel like I sprouted a chest hair just
by sniffing it entertainment purposes
may not have happened everything I feel
good smell good showering body needs and
it's all backed by Dr squatch's 30-day
money-back guarantee if you're not
satisfied get your money back no
question so click the link below and
enter promo code dsq Johns and new
customers get 20 off of your purchase of
20 or more feel good
smell fresh and now we're talking about
House of the Dragon episode 9 season one
is almost done gonna give you a spoiler
warning because last episode left us off
in a place this episode uh picks up the
mantle of that you've been warned and
with that said the king is dead Long
Live whoever survives this bus fire of a
conflict that's coming this was actually
an episode with no time Jump which I
really appreciate I've come to expect
roll with even appreciate the unique
viewing experience that the time jumps
give maybe I'm looking for excuses to
appreciate I don't know I don't care but
King viserys died at the end of the
previous episode so I'm glad we get to
see what's the word the next day a thing
that house with the dragon doesn't
always give us during the meeting the
council the Queen's like look
king viserys is dead and in his last
words when he was clearly in his right
mind and had all of his wits about him
he told me that our [ __ ] son aegon
should be king trust me that's what
happened his brain was not pumped full
of whatever chemicals pumped through
your brain when you die it he wasn't
having a DMT trip these are just his
wishes and the council was like right
we're with you your grace all the way
operation shut your [ __ ] face uncle
[ __ ] is in effect and I liked how she
was like wait a minute have you all been
planning this [ __ ] behind my back that
would be an easy Miss for a grieving
Widow who has a lot on her shoulders
including but not limited to the
succession of power but she was like you
all are talking like you had a plan
what's with the plan how did her dad
phrase it God I love greasy fawns in
this show possible deniability
oh he didn't say that well that's his
total Vibe this old guy starts snapping
back circles like you know what
oh you're dead I still have a job cool
he just kind of always keeps his job not
what you know it's who you know remember
that
It's A Life Lesson right there I thought
the Lord commander of the kingsguard was
pretty badass when they were all like
all right we're gonna kill renara we're
gonna kill a couple people but we're
gonna save so many lives this dude was
like
that ain't me folds up his cloak until
there's a king I'm out which in Westeros
means he's gone probably dead so this is
basically the whole show is we gotta
find aegon no one knows where he is
there's underground dog pit fighting not
here Westeros they would never do that
they just have children fighting these
are the scummy ass places in Westeros
that you Traverse when you're looking
for the would-be king and it is kind of
funny how this show again takes me on
this we'll call it an emotional roller
coaster it's a roller coaster of
perception really character perception
which I would see as flimsy riding if I
didn't see it as completely purposefully
done for the sake of the show so I just
appreciate it we're at a point I was
like aegon might be the next king at
least it's not as one-eyed serial killer
face brother now I'm like one-eyed
serial killer face brother might make a
better King till the next episode where
they make that guy completely horrific
and you know and thus the pendulums
things but there was a point in this
episode where you definitely feel
everything that this season was building
you to feel for this moment which is the
king is dead the glue the heart of the
realm is gone
and it's dangerous times now that's one
of the things I appreciate about this
show Patty considine was so good I'll
talk about him more in a bit he deserves
his own section of this video but at the
point they get aegon which is funny
because when he gets the dagger you know
it was a whole thing when King viserys
was telling renera about the hidden
message in the dagger about the dream of
aegon Runner was the last one to know
that and without renera passing that
knowledge on that story is just gonna
kind of go away I suppose that could be
the thing where when Eric could be like
you ever see Lord of the Rings put that
to fire you're gonna see a message I
know what the message says because
that's actually what my father was
talking about when he was dying not this
dick and in a world where it being
Westeros who knows maybe aegon's gonna
be like I should do right by the people
but it seems to me like he fell into
this and he accepted the role of King
and held up the sword after everyone was
clapping and cheering and he just likes
the feeling of being liked and then the
big boom happened I thought a bomb went
off or something in the crowd just like
blamely what the f what was that but it
was uh renise it could be reynus could
be renice I thought she bailed I thought
she was like okay while all this shit's
going I'm out she's on a dragon just
busts up through the floor yeah people
died that's just a fact she was like
here's to your day little dick we still
have one more episode in this season to
go but it's great setup for okay this
whole season was setting up for this
thing but now that his character is gone
Patty considine as king viserys props he
was incredible in the show he very much
was to the audience the viewing audience
what his character was to the realm it
was the glue the heart an entire season
building that up so when he's gone we
feel the loss we feel the directionless
nature of the world we now Traverse and
the character of viserys was so
brilliantly executed in the writing and
the acting if you look at it was episode
one right in the pilot episode of House
of the Dragon we see viserys give the
Masters the green light to hold his wife
down cut into her womb ripping a baby
from it killing her while she feels it
all because he so wanted a male Heir I
feel like any other show would have been
like and that
is how we start the villain origin story
for the show House of the Dragon then
flips it and is like and now we're going
to make that character a sympathetic
character in fact the heart and soul of
the show of the realm and when he's gone
the characters will feel the loss the
audience will feel the loss it'll be
Sadness and Sorrow that breaks the
fourth wall that's just compelling
writing to me incredible execution
writing and acting Paddock considine
crushed it this season I guess the
beginning of the end is what this
episode felt like it felt like part two
of last week's episode probably because
there was no time Jump but it also felt
like part one of two for this season
finale all right so House of the Dragon
episode 9 have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]